is due to give birth
in just a few weeks time but every day
she still walks up to 10 kilometers in
seating temperatures
to search for water high into me and me
actually the water problem here is
really affecting
everything we spend all our days looking
for water
one can't do any business to earn any
income
finding water in this part of ghana has
always been difficult
people rely on rivers and lakes or
boreholes
but with little rain now for months it's
even more of a challenge
the farther you go the more desperate
the situation
these people have been digging for hours
in the dry riverbed
just to find enough water to fill a
bucket to take home
in the midday sun temperatures are
around 40 degrees celsius
the government began building small dams
across the north of ghana in 2017
when nanado became president the project
was called one village
one dam with the aim of storing water
for the dry season
more than 500 dams have been built but
few
contain any water when the rings start
pouring here they pour
it pours and some of them would
just give way because the banks were not
either one
properly constructed or two
the intensity of the flow of water into
those dams
becomes too much for it and it gives way
[Music]
it's not just families feeling the
effects for farmers like alhassan fuseni
is a catastrophe 11 out of his cows
have died from this in recent weeks
no grass no water and they're dying one
is lucky to make a few dollars if a cow
was about to die
and a butcher is close by to slaughter
it instantly if the rains delay further
it will be a disaster
the presidents are planning more dams
bigger ones this time
and town water systems the
infrastructure
is supposed to be completed by 2023
but bido malibe isn't holding out much
hope
she is preparing for another long hot
walk to search for water
in the morning eva
north ghana